well the war to end food hunger really
depends on all of us including
corporations and our company next star
is teaming up with feeding america to
fight hunger this month christian
casadas explains how two local
businesses are doing their part to make
sure food waste is avoided
to hear that one in five individuals are
struggling with hunger is just
unacceptable for us it's a difficult
reality to accept for aubriana
martindale with smith's groceries that's
why she says ending food hunger is
everyone's responsibility we launched
our zero hunger zero waste initiative
our goal is to eliminate waste across
our operations specifically food waste
to help feed our neighbors martindale
says the program has allowed smiths to
donate 14 million meals last year alone
a tremendous effort that she says gets
everyone working together any excess
food in the store gets put through a
donation process and is evaluated and if
it's human consumable whether perishable
or non-perishable gets donated to the
food bank it just has a damaged box um
we donate to that to the food bank and
the food bank make sure the families
receive that product who are in need of
it a similar effort being put to
practice on the strip on a daily base so
at mgm resorts one of our signature
social impact and sustainability
programs is called feeding forward
and a unique component of that program
is really donating unserved food from
events to people in need launched in
2016 mgm resort's feeding forward
initiative focused on feeding more
people and wasting less food even with
the best planning when it comes to
meetings and conventions sometimes
there's going to be food that goes
unserved that food was then transferred
into disposable containers three square
food bank takes that back to their
facility a non-stop process they say to
help stop food insecurity in southern
nevada christian casarez 8 news now
now besides distributing food three
square also needs donations so you can
donate at threesquare.org and every
dollar donated provides three meals as
well